hello and welcome to I haven't washed my
hair in one week I can do whatever I
want I feel like you can always tell how
someone's doing by the way their lips
look and mine are pretty crusty today so
let's put myself on camera and see how
that goes I have finished my sixth and
final round of
chemo is this dancing I don't know what
this is this is like seizing I am
processing a lot of emotions around all
of it I have been also restless with the
idea aide of valuing my health in a new
way ever heard of it because it has been
compromised over the last 4 months when
the compromisation ends I'd like to take
authorization to lead a much more
nourishing life and throughout this
process I've looked up like recipes for
cancer patient which is kind of like a
tough thing because one my taste buds
have changed dramatically like expected
flavors don't taste expected and two
everyone's tolerance of what they can
handle and and their gut is different
and I still don't know exactly what like
my stomach can tolerate and what it
can't so the other day I got on one of
my
uh welcome to my brain there'll be a lot
of jump Cuts in this video because my
brain truly is operating at a lower
function that's why we edit this is why
we don't twitch the other day I got on
one of my search Benders that yields no
Real Results because a lot of times I
just spend a while searching sear ing
recipes and then I don't actually make
them but not this time I found this list
on eatingwell.com of uh recipes to eat
when you have cancer and I don't know
really what qualifies these things to be
on this list other than like there's
some vegetables in some of these things
so that prevents cancer According to
some research I scrolled down the list
and a smoked goua broccoli soup caught
my eye because it had pretty good
reviews and then when I looked at the
reviews I saw this one as the first one
I have had many broccoli soups this one
I did not care for lacking in flavor and
frankly just yucky I love and appreciate
food and never waste this was a waste of
time and good ingredients obviously my
interest was Peak so I got all the
ingredients to make this smoked guda
broccoli soup and then I decided to film
it because I've been very isolated and
somehow this makes me feel less isolated
I wanted to bring you along for this
ride to see if this smoked goua broccoli
soup was actually a waste of time and
ingredients or not we're doing a cooking
video back in the kitchen where I belong
because I want to cook and I can't do it
in the bathroom okay I got to start
cooking this cuz I'm going to get tired
that is one of the things that has been
so goofy I get excited about something
and then it makes me very tired like a
child it seems relatively
easy but you know I love to over
complicate seemingly relatively easy
things like that sentence even it took
me what felt like an entire hour to set
up the shoot and my camera already died
it's just too many things to think about
and I'm just simply not a detail
oriented person let's make a soup
broccoli sweet onion garlic smoked gouda
chicken broth white wine vinegar flour
and then smoked paprika and some other
sh heat a tablespoon of oil in a large
saucepan over medium heat we're going to
add the onion and cook stirring for
about 5 minutes chop an onion I don't
like a lot of onion because that's one
of the questionable things that I don't
know if my stomach can handle same with
garlic and broccoli so this is going to
be quite a soup this is an experiment on
a lot of levels chopping I know I'm even
nervous for you watching me do this it's
going to go in a saucepan and cook for
about 5 minutes oil goes in the pan
we'll put our onions in the
saucepan am I okay in the middle of that
sentence forgot how to make a cooking
video okay we're putting the onions in
onions are cooking let's chop up our
broccoli one and2 lb broccoli crowns two
mediums two mediums can you tell me what
my grandfather's up
to cuz he dead nailed it do we just chop
them we just chop them do we use the
stems I've become wildly unconfident
with my own intuition by the way cut 1
and 1/2 cups broccoli bite-sized
broccoli florettes and set aside
coarsely chop remaining broccoli I mean
it's all going to get mixed up in a
blender anyway this recipe leaves some
of the broccoli chunks and doesn't blend
it all but I might blend it all I should
clean this doing things in the kitchen
is like so cumbersome how do people do
this all the time smells great we got to
chop our garlic I'm just going to do one
clove o it's a big clove sorry for my
nose running is that gross I'll find out
when I edit it and I'm like damn that's
gross damn that's gross let me get the
flour and the paprika ready cuz they're
going to go in after the garlic goes in
for 30 seconds Trader Joe's smoked
paprika so basically I'm better than you
look how quirking cool and interesting I
am I have nothing against Trader Joe's
I'm projecting Trader Joe's intimidates
me we need a tablespoon of flour we'll
just leave that in there I'm going to
put the garlic in with the onion garlic
goes in garlic goes in for 30 seconds
then is this audio film recording garlic
goes in for 30 seconds then we're going
to add a tablespoon of flour and A4 of a
teaspoon of paprika for what and then
stir a coat then we're going to add
chicken broth 4 cups of Lo sodium
chicken broth hours in where's the
paprika I'm eyeballing it that's a lot I
think wow it smells really good four
cups of chicken broth there's four cups
in one of these I don't need this oh my
God I should be filming what's happening
in this thing I'm turning my oven on cuz
I'm going to make croutons we have to
add the chopped broccoli I'm just adding
all of the broccoli do we add all of the
broccoli oh God I think I add all the
broccoli I'm just adding all the
broccoli this seems like way too much
broccoli would you like to see this
mishap here's what's going on in here
that that doesn't seem correct it's all
going to get Bland okay they've settled
in more I'm okay with this it smells
Smokey I will tell you that bring to a
boil over high heat and then reduce to a
gentle simmer and cook stirring
occasionally until the broccoli is
tender 8 to 10 minutes was I supposed to
use this part of the
broccoli I'm not going to but I'm going
to not throw it away because I just like
to look at a potential mistake just move
it out of the way if you're unsure about
something just move it out of the way
but keep it in your peripheral vision so
that gentle hum of anxiety that familiar
hum of anxiety never leaves your side
we're going to make some croutons this
recipe suggests rye bread for croutons
I'm just using a
baguette you can do
it ow no I'm okay I'm
okay just put some olive oil on them
I'll put some salt and pepper on them I
don't care my taste buds do not know
what's going on we will bake those in
the oven soon one cup of shredded smoked
gudas we need to shred our Cheese look
what I have I'm a domestic goddess can
you eat this rind part I ate it oh that
is good oh that is good I don't know
what I'm tasting but that is good I
think I don't know if you're supposed to
eat the rind now that I just did that oh
this is oh oh what do I do bubbles are
happening I just got out of breath from
doing that little dance see this is what
happen
happens shred some cheese oh it got
under my fingernail that's disgusting
immediately this is how we get our
strength back come on baby you're a big
strong girl that's best cut me off bread
goes in so after this cooks for 10
minutes we're going to puree it in the
blender that has struggle written all
over it look at this maternal Instinct
like holding a baby does this even do
how does this even work oh it goes this
way all right we're in business when the
soup is done we're going to blend it in
the blender put it back in the pot
that's the right word and then we're
going to mix the cheese in with it that
sounds nice I am a little curious to
make more cancer friendly recipes and
see if they're actually good because
I'll tell you what when you look up
cancer friendly recipes they're a little
unsexy I'll say that but that doesn't
mean we should discount them M that is
good I think I think I might be ready to
blend but that is such a commitment I'm
going to blend
oh that's just all liquid oh okay
here we
go okay oh God oh God yeah that looks
pureed it's a bit runny let's try
putting the cheese in now it's very thin
my soup is very thin oh and the bread
okay those have croutons that cheese
went in pretty quick and it is still a
very thin soup I need 2 tbsp of vinegar
white wine vinegar salt and pepper I'm
eyeballing it I think maybe I was
supposed to add the whole
broccoli because it is a bit thin this
soup but I think that's okay cuz that's
what soup is runny right soup is runny
and liquid this is very liquid and runny
wow I'm mesmerized by it though the
cheese isn't fully melted cheese hasn't
fully melted into it here come come look
at it see here's our soup look at that
the cheese isn't fully melting in it and
I don't know how to make it melt in it
maybe I poured it all too much too fast
or maybe this is just okay I think I was
supposed to put this in there I think
this is what gives it the thickness you
know I really wasted this I'm still
going to pour myself a cup because this
looks it still looks good okay let's
throw some croutons on ooh here it is
can you oh there you go wow very runny
smoked goua broccoli soup because that
clearly was supposed to go into the soup
and didn't yes we've made some clear
mistakes bio
basically like 80% of the broccoli from
this
recipe but I'm still hopeful that this
might taste okay because guess what my
taste buds don't know the difference
this was a waste of food in some ways I
got to get a crouton in
there okay it tastes like runny broccoli
soup very runny broccoli soup but it's
pretty good M flavors are delicious and
you know my palette loves some good
flavor I think this is really delicious
had this made it in probably would have
been A+ the croutons help is not bad I
don't hate this and this wasn't a waste
hooray and that first comment you know
to each the own I have to go rest now
because this did make me a little tired
ooh ooh what is that kick in my mouth I
bit down on a pepper corn ah ooh little
firework in the lower left hand region
wow this soup is just surprising okay we
need to go now we must rest thank you
for watching this video if you want me
to make more cooking videos I think I
would really love to the kitchen has
been upgraded and is Prime and ready for
it so just let me know other than that I
don't know I really don't these
days I have to throw this in at the end
it's night time now it's like 7:00 p.m.
I put the soup in a tupperware I went
into the refrigerator to open the
Tupperware to get myself some more soup
to heat up it smelled God awful in the
whole house so that's a little side
effect of this soup and uh Elliot told
me he came in and tasted it when I
didn't know and he did not like it at
all so soup updates it smelled too bad
for me to heat up and make again so it
was good though I think when I tried it
earlier I
think we tried